Hold on. Can you read? No. What you'll notice about this guy
is not unlike the borderline illiterate classmate in fifth grade
who has to use their finger to sound out each word, that's what
Tactical Templar does with like all of the things he reads on
stream. Watch the finger move along. >> Man, is she seriously
mad that guy um has been singing over her finally moved on? Yes,
she is. [music]
Okay, we're ready for the Tactical Templar video. Jesus Christ.
Okay, I'm back. Labbotomy stream pretty soon. Pretty soon. We'll
see how it goes. All right, Tactical Templar.
We need to watch that intro again. Wasn't that intro cool? Wasn't
that intro cool? This Tactical Templar with the Pokemon news.
Okay. when she posted apparently that some dude who was hitting
her up in DMs had gotten married. >> Seemed like unnecessary
information.
>> Oh, venomous villain. Thank you for the two. Let's go.
Carrying the carrying the
I was I was broke. We're no longer
>> Alibaba 7-Eleven. Thank you for the gifted zone.
>> Venomous villain carrying this hour of the stream. This
two hours of the stream. Thank you very much. And as well as
Alibaba. Okay. Thank you guys very much. [__] Are
you doing showbo content now, too? This is not showbo content.
Okay, despite the rumors, this is not showbo content. Let's continue.
Brothers, you do not despise these female streamers enough. You
just don't. You may think that you do, but you don't. Pokemon
is in this clip right here that we're about to watch. And you're
not going to believe this, but there was a guy that was interested
in Pokemon that was DMing her for months.
She didn't even acknowledge this guy's existence. Didn't respond
to any of the DMs. Didn't do anything with this guy. This guy
is going out there going, "I really hope that she'll give me
a chance this day. I really hope she'll give me a chance this
day." this guy living on a
>> do you think that Tactical Templar is
you think he's aware of like Shelbo and that lore? Do you think
he's aware of like the level of like crazy people who go to Poky's
DMs? Cuz it sounds like this must be a celebrity for one thing
cuz she wouldn't say anything if it wasn't somebody consequential,
right? Somebody she could check back in on and see was getting
married.
Is this dude getting winded just talking? Yes. Yes.
We've learned a lot about Tactical Templar recently. Apparently,
this guy loves Lolly VTubers.
I've just learned this. I become aware of this recently.
All right. Maybe we'll watch some stuff in that vein at some
point. We'll see. Sent you a safe meme. All right. Well, I'm
I'm going keep watching this for a second. I think this has to
be like a celebrity. So, already he's like imagining himself.
Like, if I message Pokémon, I wouldn't want her to out me. Don't
worry, bro. She She'll never see a DM from you. It will never
matter. Okay. I'm guessing actually all of her DMs go through
like a third party. And this was from somebody consequential
enough that they felt they had to still pass it on to her.
So anyway, it's it's like it won't happen to you. You don't have
to worry about it. Nobody has to hate her. >> In a prayer
hoping to get her attention, she's watching these things, not
responding. The guy goes, "Okay, she's obviously not interested."
The guy moves on. He finds a girl who's willing to marry him
and he announces it on
All of a sudden, Pokemon knows who this guy is and is reading
his Instagram
>> Again, the obvious implication here is that within like
a very short time frame, this guy went from hitting up Pokey
consistently
to getting married to announcing his engagement.
Pokey likely thinks that that engagement had taken place over
a period of months and over overlapped with him hitting up her.
And so he she felt like, "Oh, this is like some tea, but it like
I don't I'm not going to do it." She's just like, "Oh, I'm gonna
make a nondescript video about it. Okay, maybe it's a little
weird, but it's not something to freak out about." And this guy
doesn't understand at all. >> And now her master plan is,
I wonder if I should DM the fiance and tell her that he was DMing
me.
No, I'm not kidding you.
She pretended this guy didn't exist.
This guy was really interested in her. He wanted to go on a date.
He wanted something from her. She didn't give him anything.
So, the guy eventually moved on.
And that right there was the crime because Pokemon
loves >> Oh, he like actually straight up doesn't understand,
right?
Like he straight up doesn't understand at all what the point
is here. He's like so disconnected from the female species that
he doesn't get it. He doesn't know what's happening. He doesn't
understand >> the attention. She loves everything to be
about herself. And this guy was giving her that. He was feeding
her ego,
>> you know, like the whole feeder syndrome. He was feeding
her bloated,
fat girl energy ego. This guy's definitely got
Pokemon inflation on his computer somewhere. Okay, 100%.
Just stuffing it. And she loved it. She loved the feeling of
control. Oh, I'm not going to respond to this guy. This guy's
not worth my time. I'm Pokemon
And then the guy moves on. He says, "You know what? This chick's
not worth it." Finds a girlfriend. finds. >> No, just to
be clear, if this was a stalker, Pokemon would not talk about
a stalker. This is a big streamer, big like influencer of some
kind who knew Pokey was single and was hitting her up and then
suspiciously got engaged very close to that. As in this guy,
she suspects he's like a player. The reason she would message
the fiance is because she's like, "Oh, nobody deserves to have
someone who would step out like that." Who got married? Maybe
got married. I I don't remember. No, just announce his
right? That's No, it's not Shelbo.
I'm just telling you what obviously has happened here based on
this and I think me listening to 5 seconds of the clip. Although
maybe the clip is maybe this is like a really bad title and the
clip says something totally different and then I'll be totally
wrong. >> A girl that's going to be his fiance
and Pokemon's first thought is I'm
mad.
This guy isn't focused on me anymore. Now he's focused on his
own life. Now he's got a a girlfriend and a
>> Tell me why this guy has been DMing me for months, trying
to link up, responding to my outfit pics, etc.
And he just announced his engagement on
And it me off because it's in that gray area of like I don't
think that this warrants messaging the girl and being like, "Hey
girl."
But also, it's
odd. Then again, maybe they're in an open rel. >> The only
thing here that's odd is that there was this guy that you didn't
give the time a day to. You didn't talk to according to you.
You didn't talk to him. You didn't respond to him. He >> Dude,
this is like such a straight incel script. I don't even like
literally this guy heard that Pokemon was talking about someone
in her DMs and he just filled in his entire life story with every
woman he's ever attempted DM to DM.
>> Instantly filled it in. >> Reban Ruben donated
$3. I would like to congratulate Shelbo on his engagement to
Poke Mane. >> Thank you so
much donation.
Massive, massive stuff. I'm actually secretly reconnecting my
headphones
to reconnect those headphones there for a second because the
[__] they started clicking again. I had to walk I
walked downstairs to get caffeine. So now I'm back. >> He
was DMing you. You weren't DMing him. So eventually he stops
DMing you and he finds a fiance.
says, "I'm >> I normally leave my headphones." Uh,
>> And you record yourself making a video, and the thing
that's really odd is that you thought this would make you look
good, but in fact, nothing could make you look worse.
>> It's hard. >> It doesn't make her look any way.
It doesn't make her look any way. The only thing I would say
is somebody pointed out there's probably a couple of like streamers
or highle influencers who just got engaged who are now like catching
questions from their fiance that they don't want to answer. You
know what I'm saying? And God bless those guys who are like actually
faithful and don't DM any other women because they're actually
they're actually probably the least trusted now. Oh, you like
delete your DMs? Oh, you just like Okay, you think I don't know
she's referring to you? something that could really break through
and demonstrate your lack of a
You left this guy on unread for months, but he was being read.
You just didn't respond to him because everything was about you
and your ego.
Well, I'm not the only one that noticed this.
So, wait,
she ignored him in the DMs. He moved on and now she's mad.
You explained it perfectly.
Auntie makes everything about her. Broke kept it pushing and
found somebody and she's getting shamed for it. Yes.
Yes. He's getting shamed
because he moves on and did the right thing and found a girl
that's willing to marry him. >> I'm I'm sorry. Is it not
like just It's just like so obvious that's not what would happen.
And I
It's so obvious. What? Man,
what do you think the odds are that Pokey even reads her own
DMs on most of her accounts? I'm guessing she's got one thing
like maybe an Insta or maybe her Twitter where she does read
her DMs where she can like filter them down a lot more. I don't
believe she reads her DMs in most places or like she has her
DMs set to followers only. This could have actually been interesting.
Like, if you try to DM Poke on some random platform, can you
do it? Hold on. Let me see if I can Let's see if I can go over
to Pokemon's actual Twitter and DM her.
Uh, boom.
I can Why does she have open DMs on here? That's bizarre that
she'd have open I don't even follow her. Well, hold on, Top Bronson.
My theory is, okay, my theory
is that she has someone else who reads her DMs and passes along
things that are relevant and that even though this was somebody
trying to slide in her DMs, it was a big enough person that the
assistant would have thought it's relevant and I'm sending it
anyway. That's what I That's why I think it's like a big influencer
or something.
>> Instead of this obnoxious
midwit who again has that fat girl energy
when it comes to her ego.
She is a glutton when it comes to her ego. She is one of the
most vain content creators I've ever seen. Everything about optics,
everything about me me. What's the perception of this? Like we
are so we are so cooked as a species and people like her are
the
textbook definition of modern females. So, she checks DMs for
people hitting on her,
then ignores them only to stalk them,
then posts a video complaining about somebody moving on only
to think about ruining their happiness all out of This is like
um this is like the GPT thing. Like, this guy's getting fooled.
I this is like actually blowing my brain up right now because
I kind of thought like okay I can still have some belief in humanity
if it's like just bots who are doing this who like don't actually
watch the clip. They're not capable of processing the clip. They
just read the comments and then they use that to interpret what
happened in the clip
and and that's now it's like a human who's
who is just reading the comments and not watching the clip, not
actually understanding the clip, right? So, it's like actually
destroying the cope I had that made me not think like the world's
doomed. It's kind of [__] up. >> Spite and
jealous. >> This is very [__] up. I'll be real.
>> And y'all are on her side, man. >> I didn't deserve
this. >> Y'all are blinded by this hips. Yeah. I don't
understand. This [__] is
>> y'all y'all are blinded by this by her hips. Y'all men
y'all are blinded by her
What? This is like a very popular image right now. What can someone
tell me? This looks like um Wizard of Oz or something like it
would be from Wizard of Oz. Sorry, not Wizard of O. Oh my god.
Alice in Wonderland. Alice in Wonderland. Alice in Wonderland.
But what is it? I said it before I saw anybody say it in text.
I instantly corrected myself. I knew I knew it was Alice in Wonderland.
Okay. Holy.
But what why is this popular right now? Why is this so popular
right at this specific point in time? >> Almost 40 and
is out here mad about some random dude. Yeah, guess what, Pokemon?
This is the truth that none of your simps will tell. >> It's
only because Teeone used it. I know Teone used it cuz I mocked
him for using it, but I thought I'd seen it like eight different
places before Tee used it. Thought I saw everybody using it.
>> Volume, your eggs are drying up faster than if they
had been [laughter] cracked right on a skillet.
You are going to >> dude Peter Molyneu must just hate his
life right like like he must just hate his life. Peter Molyneu
missed his window by like 10 years and he would have been like
a mill he would have been a millionaire easy. Stefan god.
No I'm talking about the guy who made the evolution game that
flopped.
That
Lion Head Studios, right? Steven Molyneu. I never watch Steven
Molyneu so I I wouldn't know. I always screw it up. When when
I'm awake, yeah, when I when I'm awake, I screw them up. So,
>> to hit a point in time >> where your looks are
fading, your eggs have dried up. You have no kids, you have no
husband, you are going to be miserable and alone. And the thing
is, women like this are stupid enough to think that their money
is going to be able to compensate for the loneliness, the gaping
hole in their heart. No, it's not.
No amount of cats and boxes of wine are going to be able to compensate
for what you're about to feel hit you, which is the train called
Father Time.
And the fact that you're sitting here >> making videos
about some >> There's no way
this is like,
>> dude, we're going backwards in time.
We're going like backwards in time. People are doing like the
the owns from like the early internet.
Don't these guys know that they were already humiliated off the
internet? Like the people who thought this were already humiliated
away. Like you've already been humiliated. Why Why did you just
come back and get zero new talking
Yeah. Like you just you got zero new talking points. You've all
been humiliated. All those people have left in disgrace. >> Random
person that was >> Yeah. He's like the Japanese guy on
that island, right? the Japanese guy living in the middle of
the woods who like doesn't believe Imperial Japan will ever surrender.
So even though they tell him they surrendered, even though they
dropped leaflets, he's like, "No, no, Japan never surrender."
>> Was interested in you that you treated like and then
he moved on and now you're out here to try to get some kind of
revenge.
These are the type of women that ruin it for all women.
In fact, this is the type of woman. >> No, it's not even
it's not like about the eggs. It's like this is like an attitude
that just doesn't like doesn't work in so many ways, right? Like
yeah, Pookie's rich. She could do whatever she >> It will
just be okay. >> She's not going to have any problem having
kids at any point, right? >> Donated $5. The biggest indictment
of feminism is that this insult is somehow
>> Okay, I don't believe that. No, I don't believe that.
I don't I straight up don't believe that at all. Nobody believes
that. Come on, be serious.
be serious right now. Sure, sure. Sure, sure. I'm I'm saying
that like Pokemon's probably set aside whatever she needs to
for whatever future she wants. She gets to do whatever she wants.
She's retired at like what? 32, 33, 34 Pokemon age. She is 29.
She's not even 30 yet. She's literally not even 30 yet. Okay.
And she's totally retired. She's all of her income.
There's literally nothing. She said like her life is totally
set for the rest of everything. She will never run out of money.
Her kids, if she has them, will likely never run out of money.
I just can't imagine
being in whatever position this guy's in. Okay, that he wants
to that he runs his YouTube channel and that's how he spends
most of his time and he's got enough time to be super
about getting banned from Asmin Gold's Discord, right? Whatever
this guy is doing with his life, I know that Pokemon owns him
in every possible way.
that I would say
makes it so that we should repeal the 19th amendment. Manipulative,
fake, self-absorbed, classless, gutter trash bimbo. And this
is unfortunately
the current state of content creation.
You literally left this guy on unread for months
and then you came back
and tried to ruin his life when he moved on.
>> Why did he get banned from Asold's Discord? Uh, he made
a big thing about praying
is what I heard.
Someone sent me his like he's banned from Asmin's Discord cuz
he wouldn't stop praying or something. I didn't I didn't take
a look yet. Um, apparently I don't want to I don't want to talk
about it. Apparently, this guy also has some other issues going
on. Okay. >> This is mad because she ignored him and he
moved on. >> Well, I can I can talk about it. This guy
apparently has like a KF thread or something and he covered it
on his stream. He's insane.
Apparently, he got like a CF thread. He started covering it on
his stream within like weeks,
within days, maybe. And
And it's like, bro, you don't Why Why would you do that?
>> Raise your worst thing you could do >> cuz the
>> Hold on. I I'll grab the clip. Ry sent me a clip of
it or something.
He like pulled it up on stream. A couple different people told
me he pulled it up on stream.
One second. Let me go find this. >> Can we say a prayer
for Kiwi Farms?
Absolutely. Let's Let's bow our head. Let's Let's say a prayer
for Kiwi Farms. Dear Lord, we come before you and we just pray
for the lost and broken souls
>> I'm not lying when I said
he made it skinnier. He made his night skinnier. He started getting
made fun of for being fat and he made a skinnier night. There's
a skinnier night now.
I'm not even joking. I said this the other day. I'm like, "Wait,
there's no way he made this skinnier, right?" And he made it
skinnier. He actually went and made it. There's no shot, bro.
>> Because the is this she >> Oh, wait. Hold on.
Let's finish the the prayer. I do want to finish the prayer.
>> Lord, you know that a lot of those people are in a miserable
place.
Many of them have given up, stopped trying to reach out, stopped
trying to
feel anything approaching goodness and light.
Lord, I just pray in your own way that you touch each of their
lives, that you have somebody reach out and try to bring them
back to the church so that they may know your love and grace
and
Lord, I just pray that you give them
that you find them something to do
other than
the distractions
and the I just want to make it clear that we uh listen, we laugh
at this guy not because he's praying. We laugh at this guy because
he's praying as a shield, okay? And not a shield because he's
like a s or something. Not for women. He's a He's He's using
it as a shield to distract from the fact that he loves drawn
depict
drawn depictions of children. Okay. That's his favorite thing
in the whole world. Okay. The younger the better for this guy
in terms of his like lolly enjoyment. All right. And he uses
he uses his whole Christian LAR as a shield. It's so gross.
Ignored him and he moved on. Now she's mad. The wall and the
smell of rotten eggs are close. That's right. That's
>> It's such a mind. He can pray like that and talk about
Pokemon the way he does. It's also why I suspect he's not actually
married. >> The wall is undefeated.
She should tell the girl. Uno reversed the girl with a picture
of the ring and says, "I have the ring. You left him on
And also reply uh with the rabbit tapping the clock. That would
be really
Who is that fella, bro? Too damn bad.
Is she seriously mad that guy um has been sing over her finally
moved on? Yes, she is.
Yes, she is. Because Pokemon and other girls in that space, and
I'm sure this happens with Valkyrie
>> Hold on. Can you read? No. Oh, what you'll notice about
this guy is not unlike the borderline illiterate classmate in
fifth grade who has to use their finger to sound out each word.
That's what Tactical Templar does with like all of the things
he reads on stream. Watch the finger move along. >> Bad.
Is she seriously mad that guy um has been sing over finally moved
on? Yes, she is.
Yes, she is. >> She does it like all the time. Pokemon
and other girls in that space, and I'm sure this happens with
Valkyrie and Cinnamon,
Emaru, and Extra Emily and all these other people,
they get these very flattering posts
and DMs and messages, and they do they get off on it. They feel
very flattered and they feel very important,
but it's it's not that they want to respond or that they they
like the guy or that they're going to, you know, flirt with it
just like Whoa. >> Reban Rubin donated $3. Templar probably
got the thinner curse through chain
The fact that there are people that are DMing them and interested
in them and that makes them feel good
and they don't care about anyone else.
So Pokemon left the guy on >> Thank you so much for the
three Ruben Ruben. I love you. I got to get you sometimes. Okay.
Once in a while I have to I have to poke once in a while or else
or else you'll just start phoning it in. Okay. I have to let
you know that I've got like a bar and then
otherwise you just end up phoning it in. >> He moved on
eventually and that's it. Now she's mad. Now she's mad because
she
that well she isn't all that.
that guys can move on and that bothers her because it reminds
her of choo choo father time
coming around the track.
You're This is why I've got to neg him occasionally. Ozel. Okay.
If he has his full self-esteem, he might realize he could do
anything with his life and be anywhere. And so I have to neg
him occasionally so he never looks away. So he's always always
knows he's here. Okay. If I if I just tell him he's awesome all
the time, he'll think about moving on to bigger and better places.
We can't have that. They're pushing what? 35, 40.
She looks like she's 40 now. She She's getting up there in age.
Yeah, she she's looking old. >> Trying to
>> like I I'm sorry.
That's incredibly
I just don't know.
Woman who sells products and like an entire brand based on how
how she looks looks old, looks 40, looks beat
I'm so I'm sorry, man. I >> What a [__] What
an obnoxious [laughter] [__] What a Don't DM girls
like this.
Don't DM girls like this. They'll use it to try to destroy you
to make themselves feel better about themselves.
Don't do it. It's not worth it. It's not worth it. You guys can
do
You guys can do better than a midwit girl that thinks she's a
girl boss but is what? ADIQ? A girl that has sacrificed everything
for her quoteunquote career ends up miserable, ends up alone.
She's gonna be alone. So,
don't feel bad for her. She's awful. She's miserable.
And uh it's only a matter of time.
You know, you can call it karma. You call it divine retribution.
But things have a way of uh working
>> Dude, okay. I I'm sorry.
The divine retribution of making this woman retired at 30 with
every door possible open for her. She could do anything she wants
with her life. She never has to worry about money or work again.
She just gets to choose to do whatever. I Bro,
what was she in another life for this to be the retribution out?
We have a god of justice and love, but we also have a god of
brass. >> What's up, Crow? How's it going? >> Anyway,
ladies and gentlemen, I want to thank you for watching. I want
to thank you for supporting the channel, and I'll see you next
time.
That's
Tactical Templar. The Son [__] explodes at his audience.
I'd think about it. I'd think about it, but Oh, I would think
about it.
Ah, what's this? Porter Beller gave me a clip. Hold on. Porter
Beller had a clip. Let me find it.
I was told this was some goofy. Let me see. What was it? Oh,
it's a dot move. Oh, give me a second. I got to put this on stream.
I got to put this on streamable.
How do we get it up there? What is this? What is this? I By the
way, I've not I've not spent time like figuring out what this
was about. This from a video that
seems weird, but it's not real. AI generated child art could
be the next big problem. Okay. Car. Okay. Why? Why is this taking
What the streamable? Can you go? Streamable is taking forever
here. Give me a second. We're letting this We're letting this
load up.
Wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait. Nobody's seen this
clip, right? I'm just I'm a little scared about this
Templar armor avatar for future segments. We could do a Templar
bit. I don't want to I don't want to get into bullying this guy
too much. As much as I hate this guy and he is like a huge local,
I once everyone else like when when we were doing it and no one
else was doing it, I feel fine. And then once everyone else is
in, I'm like, okay, I want to move on.
Same thing happened with uh Tom Foolery, right? It's like, okay,
now everybody else is bullying this guy. I just want to move
on. I I don't like it when it's like eight different content
creators doing all of it at the same time.
>> But this is going to open up a conversation in the coming
years. People are going to be asking this because if you have
an AI program that can generate
>> but no children were actually hurt in the creation of
this. What is going to be the public's conversation? And
there are many different topics
that I would have said to you there is no possible way that that
topic is going to go the way that it is.
>> Where are my prison bar sound effects?
Should have them somewhere here. There it is. I mean, if you
would asked me 15 years ago
like about wokeness and that whole thing, I would have said there's
no way.
There's no way that some of the more
>> of wokeism
were going to make its way into public
No,
not going to happen. But it did.
And by the way,
I just scrolled up here to look at this. >> Oh, well that's
the big thing, Shogunate. I think people have been looking into
this guy, finding like some of his old videos, and he used to
run a lot of defense for like VTubers and stuff. He used to be
like a big time
So, I don't know. I don't know what happened. Yeah, I don't know
what happened. I don't know how he decided to go into the conservative
grift. Okay. this picture and a detail that I didn't >> but
that's why he has Nuaku and uh he's got like Nuxtaku and Tecton
as his paragonss of virtue, right? Cuz they're both former Gooners
[laughter] that former said with a lot of you know we're knocking
on wood there. Okay, former Gooners
who are now for some reason conservative in some way. we noticed
was that these three girls
um in this the Wendy's have condoms in their mouth.
>> I know the picture he's talking about too. It's weird.
There's like a picture that he's talking about that I'm not going
to pull up cuz it's just goon bait. It's just goon fuel. No thanks.
No thanks. No thanks. No thanks.
Okay, what are we doing next? Oh, we did the Templar segment.
Maybe at some point we do more of the I feel like the Templar
stuff is good for Patreon to be honest with you. We want to go
through the Templar stuff. We go to the Patreon and then we we
can I can actually show like all this. It's not even toos. It's
just like weird.
It's just does like he used to do like weird
I don't think it's to at all. I just don't want to do it on stream.
That's all. That's it. That's all.